eingesperrt wegen ihres Glaubens
uliguren Kasachen die muslimischen
Minderheiten in Ching Chang
China steckt sie in Umerziehungslager
die die reden können geben den
Gefangenen eine Stimme damit sie nicht
vergessen werden
[Musik]
mein Name ist mein Name ist mamuta
abdurachim ich bin Uigure und lebe seit
2017 in Australien
ich bin ein Opfer des Völkermordes den
China im Moment vollstreckt
mein Name mein Name ist Sepp John
belasch ich bin 48 Jahre alt ich bin
geboren in Ching Chang und habe dort
gelebt
[Musik]
meine Frau ist willkürlich 2017 ins
Gefängnis gesperrt worden
[Musik]
was den Menschen in Ching Chang
widerfährt das kann sich auf der ganzen
Welt wiederholen chines die
kommunistische Diktatur China begrenzt
sich nicht auf ihr eigenes Land sie
strebt die Weltherrschaft an
[Musik]
wir sind immer wieder in die Provinz Ken
gereist das letzte Mal 2021 in die Stadt
kaschka der Hochburg der uluren
der chinesische Staat soll sie massiv
unterdrücken Peking dementiert das
vehement
die Polizei in kaschka steht an jeder
Ecke die Staatsmacht ist allgegenwärtig
[Musik]
jeden Morgen um 9 Uhr beginnt in kaschka
die offizielle Völkerverständigung
Chinesen aus dem ganzen Land kommen in
Bussen vorgefahren um die traditionellen
Tänze der ulturen zu bestaunen
[Musik]
die handch Chinesen treffen auf die
muslimische Minderheit
diese Bilder sind im Sinne der
chinesischen Staatspropaganda
[Musik]
solche Propaganda Bilder verbreitet das
chinesische Staatsfernsehen tausendfach
es hat eine ganz einfache Botschaft die
Welt soll glauben den Uiguren in jenjan
geht es gut wenn wir das überprüfen
wollen als Journalisten haben wir riesen
Probleme wir werden ständig kontrolliert
und überwacht trotzdem ist es uns bei
unserer letzten Reise 2021 gelungen drei
Mädchen zu treffen die uns eine
dramatische Geschichte erzählt haben
fast beiläufig erzählen Sie uns von
umerziehungslagern ohne das Wort in den
Mund zu nehmen um sie zu schützen machen
wie ihre Gesichter unkenntlich manche
Leute sind ein paar Fee was ist das
Passiv
es ist ein Ort zum Lernen viele Menschen
sind dort deswegen sagen manche olguren
dass sie nicht frei sind von einigen von
uns wurden Papa und Mama dorthin
gebracht
kennt ihr einige persönlich
ja mein Vater ist dort und ihr Vater ist
auch dort meinerseits zwei Jahren ihr
Vater schon seit vier Jahren
wisst ihr wann sie zurückkommen
das wissen wir nicht wir haben keine
Mitteilung bekommen wir können nur
warten
ob ihre Eltern unter den Fotos der
Gefangenen sind wissen wir nicht die
chinchang Files sind Beweismaterial aus
internen Polizeiberichten die
tausendfach das Schicksal der Gefangenen
beweisen sie bestätigen was uns die
Mädchen erzählen
das Bildmaterial ist wirklich einmalig
das hat man halt noch nie gehabt dass
man wirklich so ein bisschen ins Innere
der Umerziehungslager reinschauen kann
in die in die polizeiübungen und halt
den den Gefangenen in die Augen schauen
kann
Experten haben Satellitenbilder
ausgewertet und haben geschätzt dass
selbst wenn diese Gefängnisse nicht
überfüllt sind dass die zusätzliche
Kapazität seit 2016 bei mindestens eine
Million zusätzliche Menschen liegt das
heißt ist es also durchaus möglich dass
weiterhin ein oder vielleicht sogar zwei
Millionen Menschen in der Umerziehung in
hochsicherheitsanstalten sind
es sind grausame Bilder die zeigen wie
brutal Chinas macht habe die Uiguren
unterdrücken die Bilder stammen von 2018
aus einem Umerziehungslager in Ching
Chang sie belegen die Massen
internierungen und kulturelle
Vernichtung der muslimischen Minderheit
für das Studium religiöser Schriften 34
Jahre Gefängnis und sie beweisen dass
die Befehle von Präsident Chi selbst
kommen
[Musik]
ja die Dokumente belegen das hygienping
erstens ganz genau informiert war dass
wir zum Beispiel auch wusste dass die
Lager 2018 dann wegen dieser Massen
internierungskampagne massiv überfüllt
waren und das er daraufhin ganz klar
Instruktionen gegeben hat dass die Lage
erweitert werden müssen neu gebaut
werden müssen und mehr polizei und
Sicherheitskräfte zum Bewachen der Lager
eingestellt werden müsste
in Ching Chang soll es mehr als 300
Lager geben dies hat ein australischer
Think Tank anhand von Satellitenbildern
dokumentiert wir haben bei unseren
Reisen immer wieder versucht Zugang oder
zumindest Einblicke zu gewinnen aber wir
stießen an Grenzen die Lager sind gut
bewacht und abgeschirmt einmal konnten
wir von außen drehen
wir haben mit Opfern gesprochen sie
haben unterschiedliche Schicksale aber
sie haben eins gemeinsam sie sind alle
auf der Flucht vor dem chinesischen
Staat leben in Australien oder Amerika
und sie alle kämpfen gegen das Vergessen
wollen dass wir nicht wegschauen
wir sind nach adelite gefahren die Stadt
in Australien liegt an der Küste sie ist
berühmt für ihre vielen Festivals das
Schicksal der Uiguren in chingyang
scheint tausende Kilometer entfernt
genau genommen
10.500 km
für Mammut abdudu RIM ist es ganz nah er
war mit seiner Familie nach Australien
ausgewandert
seine Frau Muharrem musste aber wegen
ihres Reisepasses mit den Kindern nach
qaschka zurückfahren die Polizei nahm
ihr dort den Pass ab sie verdächtigten
sie eine islamistin zu sein
[Musik]
jeder der eine eigene Familie hat
versteht den Schmerz und die
Verzweiflung wenn einem die Kinder und
die Frau weggenommen werden
ich habe ihre Stimmen seit Mai 2017
nicht mehr gehört
es bringt mich um sie nicht zu sehen
ein paar Bilder von ihnen zu bekommen
würde mich unglaublich glücklich machen
[Musik]
die Nachricht von den Ching Chang Police
Files hörte habe ich sofort jedes
einzelne Foto angeschaut
nicht das Fahndungsfoto meiner Frau zu
finden ist wahrscheinlich besser sonst
traumatisiert mich das nur wieder
so viele unschuldige Seelen die nur
wegen ihrer Religion ihrer Herkunft
wegen ihres Namens und ihres Glaubens
wegen ihrer Existenz inhaftiert sind
diese Fotos sind erschütternd und
verfolgen dich
viele haben Familienmitglieder und
Freunde auf den Fahndungsfotos entdeckt
ich hoffe die Welt versteht jetzt das
Ausmaß der Verfolgung
die chinesische Regierung verteidigt
sich weist immer wieder auf
Terroranschläge hin die Islamisten in
den letzten Jahren in der Provinz Chin
Chang verübten dabei starben mehr als
450 handchinesen die Regierung stellt
die Muslime unter Generalverdacht und
sperrt sie weg
jedem müsste jetzt klar sein die
Machthaber in China haben entschieden
die uigurische Identität Kultur und
Religion auszulöschen
sie wollen dass wir in der chinesischen
Kultur aufgehen
jeder Abweichung von der chinesischen
Leitkultur gibt den Autoritäten einen
Vorwand um uns einzusperren
du kannst wegen deiner Religion oder
deiner Herkunft wegen deiner Kultur
Probleme bekommen
weil du zum Beispiel betest oder fastest
oder an einem Gottesdienst teilnimmst
oder weil du deine Sprache lernst oder
sie lehrst oder deine Traditionen lebst
China ist mächtig jeder der es wagt
Peking und Präsident Ski zu kritisieren
muss mit wirtschaftlichen Konsequenzen
rechnen gerade die westliche Welt hat
Angst davor
die Weltgemeinschaft hat nicht genug
unternommen um China zu stoppen
wir behaupten dass wir an den Slogan nie
wieder glauben
aber im Fall der Uiguren gilt das nicht
in the future die Welt hat nicht gegen
China aufbegehrt
sie haben nur sehr vorsichtig Kritik
geübt und haben Chinas Machthaber
gebeten ihre Unterdrückungspolitik zu
ändern aber die Welt hat keinen Druck
ausgeübt
nächste Station auf der Spurensuche um
Chinas Völkermord begreifbar zu machen
ist ein Ort irgendwo in Texas wir sagen
nicht wo genau Sektion bila schlägt er
will das nicht denn der chinesische
Staat verfolgt ihn weil er die
Verbrechen an der muslimischen
Minderheit aufdeckte tausende von
Muslime hat er aus Ching Chang zur
Flucht verholfen die Sky ist dieser Mann
ist mehr als ein Jahr im
Umerziehungslager in Ching Chang
interniert gewesen
mit unserer Hilfe kam er frei und konnte
China verlassen und seine Familie
wiedersehen
wir haben serekchan bielage in den
letzten Jahren immer wieder getroffen
einmal sind wir zu ihm in seiner Heimat
kasastan gereist er hatte eine
Organisation gegründet die vor allem
muslimische Frauen aus den Lagern
befreite er brachte uns zu den Opfern
Augenzeugen des Grauens
sie war mehrere Monate in einem
Umerziehungslager eingesperrt er lebte
einen Albtraum der permanenten
Überwachung
wir durften nur zweimal am Tag auf die
Toilette jede Frau hatte nur zwei
Minuten Zeit wenn wir länger brauchten
dann wurden wir mit einem Knüppel
geschlagen
musste Zwangsarbeit leisten sie zeigte
uns damals ihre Videos die chinesische
Regierung beschuldigt sie eine
Terroristin zu sein
im Juli 2017 wurde ich in ein Lager
gesteckt ich hatte Kasachstan besucht
und sie sagten sie müssten jetzt meine
Gedanken reinigen die wären vergiftet
Kasachstan sei ein terroristischer Staat
gegen das Leid der muslimischen
Minderheit in chinchang zu kämpfen ist
bis heute die Lebensaufgabe von sergejan
bilasch er ist ein Chronist des
Völkermordes er will mit seinen vielen
augenzeugen berichten die Welt zwingen
hinzuschauen
meine Organisation nimmt jeden Tag von
muslimischen Kasachen die
gefangenengeschichten auf
ich glaube die Fakten sind eindeutig der
Völkermord der Chinesen an dem
muslimischen Minderheiten ist belegt
wir haben es bewiesen wir haben 10.000
opferberichte aufgenommen
auf was wartet die Welt brauchen wir
noch weitere Ching Chang Files brauchen
wir davon 100
und die Welt übt nur leise Kritik an
China das ist alles
keine Politik die China zwingt den
Völkermord zu stoppen
es ist eine große Schande
und eine geschichtliche Tragödie
die Tragödie wiederholt sich China hat
schon einmal vor den Augen der
Weltöffentlichkeit eine ganze Kultur
vernichtet die Tibeter vom mehr als 70
Jahren marschierte China in Tibet ein
free Tibet freies Tibet das galt als das
große Versprechen dass die Welt den
Tibetern gegeben hat doch man hat sie
vergessen einer will das ändern und
kämpft weiter 99
wir sind an die Westküste Amerikas
gereist in die Nähe von San Francisco
dort lebt der Tibeter don'dap manchen
auch erst auf der Flucht vor China weil
er die Wahrheit über den Völkermord an
seinem Volk erzählt
2008 habe ich einen Film über die
Menschenrechtslage in Tibet gedreht
das brachte mir sechs Jahre Gefängnis
ein ich habe meine Familie in Tibet seit
elf Jahren nicht mehr gesehen ich habe
es geschafft zu fliehen ich fühle mich
verpflichtet alles zu tun um auf das
Schicksal der Tibeter aufmerksam zu
machen meine Entschlossenheit alles für
die Rechte der Tibeter zu tun wird
niemals aufhören
[Musik]
2008 waren die ersten Olympischen Spiele
in Peking eine riesen Show mit der sich
die aufstrebende Macht der Welt
vorstellen wollte viele hofften dass
China einen demokratischen Weg nehmen
würde
don'dap warnchen hielt das schon damals
für einen naiven Glauben er tretet den
Film die Angst hinter sich lassen
leaving 4 behind
er reiste durch sein Land und gab der
tibetischen Bevölkerung eine Stimme
Bauern Mönche und Arbeiter sprachen
darüber wie Pekings Machthaber die
tibetische Kultur unterdrückten dafür
sperrten ihn die chinesische Regierung
ein heute 14 Jahre später sind die
Verletzungen verheilt aber die Lage
seines Volkes hat sich nicht verbessert
im Gefängnis haben sie mir keine Fragen
gestellt aber sie haben mich gefoltert
und geschlagen
mein ganzer Körper war geschwollen das
ging drei Monate so
die Schwellungen waren so schlimm dass
ich meine Hände nicht mehr erkennen
konnte
die Menschenrechtslage in Tibet wird
immer verzweifelter deshalb kommt es
immer wieder zu Selbstverbrennungen
Präsident hier ist wie ein zweiter Mao
unter dem Vorwand staatlicher
Unterstützung und Förderung werden die
tibetische Kultur und der Buddhismus
gezielt ausgelöscht
die tibetischen Kinder werden von ihren
Eltern getrennt und in Internate
gestecktische Rasse wird ohne Rücksicht
dezimiert und
Kai Müller ist der Chef von
international campaign for Tibet
Deutschland er spricht von einem
Frontalangriff Chinas auf die tibetische
Kultur zum Beispiel werde die Sprache
nicht in den Schulen gelehrt
so dass eben diese Kinder eigentlich gar
keine Tibeter mehr sind wenn sie aus
diesen Schulen kommen sie sind aber und
das ist auch dass das zusätzlich fatale
sie sind auch keine Chinesen weil sie
weder richtig tibetisch noch richtig
Chinesisch sprechen im Endeffekt bleibt
ihm dann nichts weiteres übrig als sich
als billige Arbeitskräfte auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt zu verdienen
80 Prozent der Kinder in Tibet Leben in
Internaten getrennt von ihren Eltern das
Staatsfernsehen führt sie als Beispiel
gelungener Integration vor
unabhängige Berichte gibt es seit langem
nicht mehr aus Tibet journalisten dürfen
nur an staatlich organisierten Touren
teilnehmen
China bei wacht streng das Bild dass die
Welt von tibe zu sehen bekommt der
Konflikt und das Leid des tibetischen
Volkes sollen in Vergessenheit geraten
ist ein Testfall genauso wie chingyang
ein Testfall ist dafür wie die
internationale Gemeinschaft auf diese
Politik der KP reagierte wenn sie es
weiterhin so zögerlich und man muss
sagen in vielen Bereichen auch
desinteressiert tut und ich rede nicht
nur von der Politik sondern auch von der
Wirtschaft dann müssen wir damit rechnen
dass die KP sich ermutigt fühlt in
anderen Bereichen vielleicht in der
Außenpolitik noch weiter noch
aggressiver zu gehen
der Dalai Lama das geistige Oberhaupt
des tibetischen Volkes ist ein Symbol
für den Kampf der Tibeter um
Selbstbestimmung ein Symbol für Frieden
und Freiheit
einst war er ein internationaler
Superstar den sogar die Kanzlerin Merkel
zu Beginn ihrer Amtszeit empfing China
protestierte heftig dagegen es kam zu
keinen weiteren Treffen
don'dap Banken musste erleben wie der
Aufstieg Chinas zur Supermacht immer
mehr Länder dazu brachte wegzuschauen
sie hatten Angst dass sich China
abstraft der weltweite Aufschrei free
tibet ist verstummt don't wannchen
versucht gegen das Schweigen
anzusprechen
ich habe vor kurzem 15 europäische
Länder besucht die führenden Politiker
haben sich nicht getraut mich offiziell
zu empfangen stattdessen sind wir in
Restaurants gegangen ihre Länder haben
lukrative Wirtschaftsbeziehungen mit
China wo sie viel Geld verdienen die
Welt hat sich zum Sklaven der
chinesischen Wirtschaft gemacht und sie
kann deshalb nicht zu ihren Werten
stehen die sie Predigt
nun gibt es die zeitenwände das Treffen
des russischen Präsidenten Putin mit dem
chinesischen Präsidenten Chi haben sie
sichtbar gemacht der Krieg in der
Ukraine zeigt dass die beiden Despoten
bereit sind anzugreifen sie nutzen das
Wegschauen des Westens gnadenlos aus
Grund ist brutalen Kriegs in der Ukraine
hört man jetzt auch vermehrt Stimmen die
sagen das Wegschauen funktioniert nicht
nicht nur nicht mit Putin sondern auch
nicht mit Hygin Ping auch nicht mit den
Figuren und das ermutigt mich denn ich
denke es findet ein Umdenken statt eine
Erkenntnis dass man diese
Menschenrechtsverbrechen wahrnehmen muss
dass diese Menschenrechtsverbrechen
nicht nur isoliert sind das hat auch was
mit uns zu tun das kann auch uns treffen
denn dieses Regime das zu diesen Taten
fähig ist und willens ist mit dem sind
wir wirtschaftlich abhängig haben uns
abhängig gemacht mit diesem Regime
die Ching Chang Files geben den Opfern
ein Gesicht
Mammut abdudu rim
sehr schön
haben ihnen eine Stimme gegeben
ihr Schicksal zeigt wegschauen und
weghören ist gefährlich denn es geht
auch um uns